oh
smoke from the fingertips a classic
magician's trick and my favorite bit of
chemistry when I was a kid here's how to
do it first put a ceramic plate or mug
in the freezer then cut off the Striking
surface from a box of matches this
contains red phosphorus I peeled off
just the red phosphorus layer and then
folded it into a tent with the red
phosphorus facing down then I retrieved
my very very cold ceramic from the
freezer and placed the tent on top of it
when red phosphorus Burns one of the
products is white phosphorus which
condenses on the cold ceramic we're left
with a waxy goop that must cool down
completely before you touch it when it
was time I wiped some on my finger and
then rubbed my fingers together
producing just enough heat for the white
phosphorus to react with oxygen in the
air to form tiny particles of phosphorus
oxides that drift away as smoke
[Music]